Pankaj mishra is it a historian and
novelist and is a recipient of Yao
universities,
Windham Campbell literature prize born
in north India.
His work has appeared in the New York
Times time.
The Guardian and the independent and his
books include an end to suffering the
Buddha in the world from the ruins of
empire and he's latest age of anger,
a history of the present,
which explains how the wider embrace of
mass politics,
technology and the pursuit of wealth and
individualism has cost billions of drift
and the demoralized world.
Welcome to the show Pankaj.
Thank you for kindness.
Thanks for having me.
What I know of your work suggests to me
that you are addressing themes that have
interest did us on under the skin and
driven us w w w but on a huge scale.
You're trying to address there the
essence of what we've been trying to
tackle on a global scale.
Your latest book,
age of anger.
You're talking about rage that that this
is a sort of,
this is a time that is determined by
rate.
Are you saying that this is,
this is cross culturally regardless of
where you are in this particular
economic story?
Like whether it's like the claps of
empire that you know,
and nostalgia that's been experienced in
this country or the United States where
rage is,
feels like a very present emotion,
rage and despair on recent visits to
America.
I sort of felt enough the few public
spaces that I was in a sense a sense of
a society ill at ease with itself.
So like,
and I've experienced it in these two
western nations,
but you're saying in India is this also
a uh,
a modern cultural,
the at the center of rage?
Well,
the,
the experience of disaffection or rage
is at this moment truly global,
truly common amongst you know,
nations regardless of where they are in
the,
so called,
you know,
uh,
this,
this particular tragic tree of,
of economic growth.
So in the advanced countries as well as
the developed world,
the developing countries and so on,
so forth.
And I think it's because in,
in a,
in a context like the United States,
which has enjoyed a great deal of power
for a long time,
a lot of people feel that,
uh,
the future and this is an unprecedented
shift would be considerably worse then
what they have been accustomed to,
what the parents and grandparents that
they are not really passing on.
You know,
it was to the children or the
grandchildren in wish they can actually
hope to flourish.
And this is important package because
progressivism is the defining attribute,
the essence of the story.
So once progression stops,
once the next generation of things,
hang on a minute,
things are getting worse.
We're not going to own our houses,
we're not going to have jobs.
We were already mired in debt.
The whole thrust of our national
identities is undermined,
is the crux of the crisis.
Uh,
you know,
progress was,
the substitute was a replacement for
God.
This notion of continuous improvement
that was truly radical when we killed
off God,
when we moved away from traditional
religion be devices,
new belief system,
that there will be continuous progress.
And we have revised our existence on
this fact,
so I mean we must not underestimate the
radical shifts we are undergoing right
now.
So I suppose if you were living in a
culture that is experiencing continued
economic growth and progression or at
least a significant portion of the
population are experiencing it enough to
maintain the momentum,
then there is no need for God
particularly that it when the idea of
God is often eh demonstrated through
ancestor worship,
we are like our ancestors.
We live like them,
that we are connected to this origin
myth,
this origin story,
and through these rituals we connect to
them.
This is our relationship with God.
We are part of the whole,
when you see continual progression,
when you've seen an advancement of
mankind and obviously the shifts
philosophically that occurred a couple
of hundred years ago that you mentioned
at the beginning of this conversation,
it's very easy to see us as separate
from God,
God as the idea of originator creator
progenator.
Absolutely.
It's a,
it's a radical idea in or some,
someone warned about this,
that progress is the false gold.
The chip when he said that God is dead
and we haven't faced up to the
consequences.
This is what he was talking about,
that we've given our belief in a
transcendental authority.
We've given up believe in this God who
lays down laws,
who orders our societies.
We have decided to go do it all by
ourselves and we have invested our faith
in progress.
But this is a false religion.
And I think in many ways this moment of
Neil is in that pc today,
globally is this realization that this
religion is faltering,
that there are not enough believers in
the religion of progress.
This is the biggest shift.
This is what I'm really talking about in
my book.
And that is what I mean,
that we need to have a broader framework
to understand what is going on today.
I mean,
there are obviously many aspect of this,
um,
the economic inequality and of obviously
a lot of the rage is fuel by people
thinking that the promises happy and
unrealized,
they've been fulfill.
They've been cheated,
they've been deceived.
But it's also because they have been
promised a great deal,
especially in the last three decades of
globalization.
Did you ever believe when the,
um,
sort of the,
the research an ethno nationalism fails
to deliver and I suppose there is a
version of ethno nationalism or least
sort of a re a religiously led ethno
nationalism in India also when I suppose
when these modalities foul or deliver,
there will be further disappointment and
further rate.
Or just to ask you a sort of a personal
question,
presuming a,
if you grew up in a village in India,
I'm guessing your religious town.
So you had a religious talk about
bringing to you believe in God and what
kind of religion were you raised in?
Personally?
I mean I,
I think of myself as someone who's been
iridium irredeemably be secularized in
the sense that I cannot be religious in
the way my parents are religious,
religious in the sense of thinking that
everything that happens in the world is
due to God is because there is a hidden
invisible force behind all of it.
And,
and then everything that happens can be
explained with reference to this figure.
Now that is,
it will be that I now can no longer
enter.
But when you begin,
when you,
when you are in proximity to it,
you do realize that the big shift
really.
Um,
and,
and you see that happening right now,
that shift happened here a long time
ago.
In places like India,
you can still see it happening.
Is this shift from belief in
transcendental authority to this belief
in progress,
in material improvement?
Isn't that just a different form of
transcendent or authority?
Well,
that was,
that was the mistake.
A lot of people in the 19th century were
pointing to Dostoevsky or nature that
once you bring down the Kingdom of God
onto earth,
you will have trouble.
Once you start thinking that what is
promised to you in the afterlife can be
recreated on earth.
When you start thinking in those terms,
then you've set yourself up for cruel
disappointment.
Yes.
Also,
it seems that we've become quite muddled
in our interpretation of myth.
It seems to me,
even when I hear the phrase after life,
uh,
how the resonance of that for me
personally is now when my material,
human life as Russell,
the individual where my ego life ceases
to be the dominant driving principle for
my existence,
I will experience inadvertent Commerce,
Heaven,
paradise freed from the ego.
So that,
you know,
when,
when I see sort of perennial messages
between Hinduism,
Buddhism,
Christianity,
and believe me,
I know very little about all three of
those theologies,
just enough to know that there seems to
be an idea of essence and even the more
folkish and uh,
I'm assuming less academic understanding
that one imagines that your parents may
have had,
I don't know,
your,
that could have been a professor of
theology.
I don't know if,
I'm guessing when people talk about
religion and sort of quite folkish terms
of a transcendent or fora a got this
basically governing everything I can
sorta eve like even with my limited
understanding of the mechanics of the
material world,
I can see a use for that as a,
as an analogy,
I can see a use for the idea of supreme
or transcendent,
hopefully benevolent or authority.
Well,
you know,
I mean it has become hugely fashionable
to mock religion or people who are
religious as essentially superstitious,
ignorant,
barbaric.
But we forget that religion is a huge
source of constellation.
It helps people accommodate,
um,
helps people to accommodate themselves
to grief,
to loss,
to disappointment and disappointment is
the fate for most people.
Yes.
And in fact possibly all people.
I mean cause sometimes when it's
presented in terms of a consolation,
like that's sort of sort of common new
atheist argument,
oh it's for Sakos to,
for constantly,
but I sort of feel like you are going to
die.
The material world isn't going to make
you happy.
Your primal drives are going to be
insufficient in making you satisfied.
Your Ego is going to let you down,
everything's going to fail you,
so you're going to need constellation.
And so on that side as well as
constellation eight becomes a kind of
creed,
it becomes a kind of purpose.
It becomes a kind of meaning.
And I don't think a fabricated one
either.
I think a necessary ultimate,
a central one.
Whilst I recognize that most religions
have cultural accouterments of their
time that are unhelpful,
prejudicial,
you know,
like those are the things that I try
personally to look beyond to this sort
of powerful truths beneath them.
Now,
uh,
again,
Pankaj very the beginning of our
conversation,
you'll have,
you said you're very interested in the
important shift in the last couple
hundred years,
philosophically,
and we mentioned colonialism and
industrialization as two components.
Is that,
I'm interested in the philosophical
component.
I know you're talk about voltaire and
Russo.
Uh,
the philosophers were a little earlier
than that,
but tell us what their significance is.
No,
I use these figures to highlight certain
contradictions in the modern project
which were apparent before and modern
societies came into being,
you know,
in the late 18th century,
put it very,
very broadly.
People,
uh,
in the late 18th century we're faced
with this large question that okay we
are moving away from societies,
from a world in which the church was
important in which belief in God was
important.
[inaudible] the monarchy was all
powerful.
We are moving towards societies where
people are going to devise a social
contract for themselves,
uh,
where people are going to use individual
reason,
where people are going to use the new
insights of science to master nature.
So these were the big debates happening
during the late 18th century.
You know,
what we now call the moment that we now
call the enlightenment,
the two major figures of this,
uh,
of this enlightened where voltaire and
Russo and the debate,
the conflict between them emerges
because full there is offering a model
and a blueprint for society that we are
more or less living in today,
which is a society driven by self
interest,
by the entrepreneurial spirits,
by self interested individuals competing
with each other,
using the ideas of science to advance,
to expand,
to expand their powers.
And Rousseau who comes from very
different backgrounds,
social backgrounds also.
What was the difference?
Well,
he,
he's known poverty.
He's known deprivation,
um,
in,
in his,
in his early years.
We're on the side even forever.
It's on a path and I see all our
mufflers,
film,
streaks,
yard,
why he knife fights.
So he comes to,
he comes to Paris and find themselves
alienated by this new world of these
philosophers talk to each other who were
very interested in forming alliances
with powerful people,
including,
you know,
some of the most powerful monarchs of
the day because they think the monarchs
are the right people,
you know,
sort of early version of the new concept
today who sidle up to presidents and
prime ministers and offer them advice.
And you know,
here's what you should do in order to
modernize your society.
So this kind of rhetoric,
uh,
Russo is completely against and he's
talking about human needs,
the needs of the human soul.
And,
and,
and he thinks that the society premised
on self interest on vanity,
on imitation,
on people trying to keep up with the
Joneses,
trying to imitate the rich,
the wealthy,
the famous is a recipe for all kinds of
disorders.
To use a word we,
we,
uh,
brought up earlier,
all kinds of psychological disorders.
And he said he's a sort of acute
psychologist of the human soul,
partly because he himself is suffering
from all kinds of problems.
Envy being one of them.
[inaudible] Santino he was at Maine.
Well,
it's a sort of compound of emotions,
envy,
a sense of humiliation,
feeling of powerlessness and it's sort
of large restlessness.
You think it might mean a lot of it,
a lot of that.
And in fact,
what I try and argue in the book that we
are sort of looking at a global epidemic
of reason.
Timo,
where large numbers of people feel this
emotion importantly for the most part.
And when the moment comes as it came
during brexit and during,
during the trump election,
it erupts volcanically.
So Russo in many ways is anticipating
the pressures,
the intolerable strain this new society
promotes around self interest and vanity
is going to put on the human soul.
All right?
He sort of prophesies is in a sense that
this will lead us to this crisis.
It will lead us to a spiritual crisis.
Russo also,
he talks about like the noble savage.
Is that right?
The idea that innately we are connected
to that there is a,
in simple,
uh,
prehistoric or traditional cultures,
there is a beauty.
There is a grace that human
[inaudible].
You know what's,
what's actually interesting,
uh,
what is in fact I'm creating this
particular image in Rousseau's.
Mine are the discoveries European
travelers are making in the new world
when they're encountering indigenous
peoples in these places.
They're bringing back reports of how
these societies work.
So the whole idea of people living in
nature.
This is a sort of particular
construction that Rousseau,
someone like Rousseau absorb many among
many other people and and uses that to
critique this new society that is coming
into being,
you know,
compassion for instance,
is hugely important to Rousseau.
He thinks the innate revulsion we feel
at the sight of someone else's
suffering.
That should be the basis of the social
contract,
right?
That tried to use that as a feel.
It's interesting that you talk about
these essential bases that political
movements and political moments are
somehow ultimately underwritten by inner
phenomena or inner frequencies.
That Rousseau argues that compassion
should be the basis for our social
contracts.
And what we're experiencing now,
you argue in your book is rage as the
determinant that w or respond to more a
feeling of worthlessness.
And like this for me seems most familiar
and like one of my frustrations is to
see the way that brexit has subsequently
been packaged by the sort of,
certainly in terms of the media that
dominant,
uh,
writers of our story that the dominant
cultural commentators,
oh,
what brexit means is racism.
The ordinary people are racist.
And I think that that that is the kind
of reductive ism that led to brexit.
I think.
I think that what actually has happened
is a breakdown between the proletariat
and the bourgeoisie that the bourgeoisie
and no longer interested in representing
the interest of ordinary working people,
ordinary working people have began to
recognize that and while certainly
concerned about migration and racism,
how could they not be part of a
narrative given how much those ideas are
propagated through mainstream media?
Like I think it's more important than
that.
I think the shift is between a middle
class intelligentsia sort of abandoned,
ordinary working people to form a new
alliance with the powerful and to
demonstrate their radicalism merely
through superficial allegiances with
identity politics,
identity politics as like,
oh no,
well we're very good on gender rights
were very good and the quality in our
race without consequence,
you know,
no longer addressing the key issue of
all societies.
How do we control the powerful,
how do we confront the powerful,
how do we bring about equality,
fairness as a society based on the
compassion that you said that Russo's
I feel it's a huge mistake to judge
people who vote for trump or who voted
for brexit as racists.
It's counterproductive apart from
anything else.
It's wrong.
It's,
it's,
it's totally wrong.
A lot of people who voted for trump also
voted for Obama the biggest hoax of our
times.
Um,
so what a Bama is the biggest hoax
finding.
So I think so.
It's interesting because we've had an
academic in here a little while ago.
I,
Hindi Andrews is professor of sociology
and Black Studies at Birmingham
University who said that trump is a more
authentic or better president for black
America than a Bama because it no longer
conceals submerged inequalities and
ongoing racism was the embodiment of new
liberal chic
and managed to conceal as your other
guests said,
a whole range of grotesque inequalities
through this very seductive personal
style he had,
you know,
we getting on a different subject
altogether,
but I think in many ways Obama and eight
years of Obama,
right?
Enabled someone like Donald Trump and if
you don't see this connection,
if we insist on thinking of Donald Trump
as someone who just arrived in the
United States from somewhere in Mars,
we are going to miss this.
Yeah.
Is your age in a desperate attempt to
continue the neo liberal narrative?
Trump is presented as some kind of
grotesque anomaly,
a product of racism when he is precisely
a product of neo liberalism is precisely
the end point.
Like,
how can people,
how does society not have fest are
festering sense of separation and eh and
fear of otherness when we've just
experienced 2030 years have been pumped
up like anti-islamic sentiment sort of
like pre nine 11 at these stories have
been going on for a long,
long while and he said,
it feels to me that this moment is
simply some someone's just drew like
ridden that wave a wave that sort of
being created by cyclonic racism and
ongoing
prejudice.
I think,
I mean,
you know,
trump is the image that we don't really
want to confront of us in the mirror and
it's because we keep thinking of this
other era of which most of us people who
write in,
in,
in you work for the mainstream media,
I include myself are beneficiaries,
have been beneficiaries of the system,
our lives,
our material lives have improved
enormously in the last 2030 years.
So we have enormous investments in
keeping this particular narrative going.
And one way of doing it is to say that
these people who bought for trump are
deplorables,
are racists,
and that there is something like true
liberalism out there.
If only people would listen.
If only people could understand what is
good for them.
Instead they follow the racist thing
stinks and vote for trump.
This is a deliberate misdiagnosis.
Uh,
this is,
this is a real distortion of what has
been happening,
not just in the United States elsewhere.
Okay.
The fact,
you know,
going back to,
so the promise of freedom with which the
modern world begins.
Freedom from authority,
freedom from custom,
the fact that for many people this has
become hugely,
hugely impossible to realize because of
the nature of our institutions,
the increasing centralization of power,
the fact that most people find
themselves reduced to cogs in a,
in a,
in a boss machine,
most people find very little stability,
very little dignity in their working
lives.
All this has led to this moment that we
are experiencing today.
You know,
this,
you know,
on one hand this extravagant promise of
freedom,
prosperity,
and then the fact of structural
inequality.
The fact that mobility is blocked for
most people unless he belonged to the
right family,
unless you belong to the right dynasty,
unless you belong,
unless you go to the right college.
And you know,
this is not something that I'm saying or
a few people are saying.
This is now been demonstrated
empirically with all kinds of data.
Um,
the fact that college educated people
have a huge advantage over everyone
else.
That morbidity has been blocked for
large numbers of people.
So we are looking at a massive
dysfunction in which all the founding
promises of the modern world look almost
impossible to fulfill
if feels like the conditions are correct
for genuine radicalism,
for real radical change.
It seems that there's potential for
explosive global change.
Where do you think that it's,
I mean it's a big question.
Do you think those societies to
sectarian two fractured cause?
I like it because I'm a public
performer.
I am often [inaudible] and I work in a,
mostly in this country at the moment I
like,
I'm often in regional spaces of with
1500 or a couple of thousand people
doing stand up comedy.
And one of the things I talk about is
how the powerful continually invite
ordinary working people to I want to
enough,
uh,
suspiciously when I as a veil for the
actions of the powerful.
So like I sort of watch people's faces
as I say,
you know,
you will always do what you've always
done.
Blame other people that are basically
the same as you that don't have power
for things that only powerful people can
affect or change.
So,
and then in the show I say,
fuck Muslims,
fuck with disabled.
Fuck the white working class,
middle class.
Fuck you.
Fuck can you thanks for your vote.
See you in four years.
And I see that this divides the room.
I see that people are uncomfortable in
letting go of more immediate sense of it
is the problem I feel sometimes with the
mind is there are certain stories that
are easier to believe.
There is stories that are more visceral
that relate more to our experience of
being human.
It's hard to,
concealed power is very difficult to
understand.
By its very nature,
it's,
I mean,
you know,
the other factor is that in the West and
western Europe and the United States,
we haven't had mass movements for change
for a very long time.
You know,
if you think about it,
the last time we had mass movements,
large numbers of people participating in
them against the war for civil rights,
feminist movement,
this,
these all happened in the 1960s and
seventies.
So whole memory of popular participation
in politics of large numbers of people
coming together for a particular cause
of justice,
bonding together,
feeling degree of solidarity.
That memory has been x,
you know,
completely expunged
possibly because of the success of the
philosophy that you said Voltaire was
exemplary of that.
We do regard ourselves as individuals
now that liberalism that it means
freedom to be an individual and freedom
to meet be an individual means freedom
to be disconnected and an inability to
see your identity is integral to the,
to the roles,
relationships and destinies of people
that are basically just the same as if
we live in,
in an interdependent society.
Yes.
That we live in an interdependent
world.
Um,
you know,
this is something the Buddhist started
talking about 2,500
years ago.
I wrote a book about the put that where
this team feature is a great deal.
The team of interdependence,
which the would that invoke in order to
critique the rising notion of
individualism at the time.
I mean this,
this,
this notion of the individual self that
has to express fine,
that has to consolidate itself with all
kinds of material advances and,
and,
and guide of intellectual growth,
which is what has become so dominant,
especially in the last three decades.
A kind of hyper individualism,
which is unconstrained by any
institution,
you know.
Mm.
That is what has been propagated and
also swallowed whole by large numbers of
people,
which has really frayed,
so many social sorted out at ds,
which is again,
sort of really destroyed I imagination
in some crucial ways.
You know,
whole ways of acting in the world upon
the world has been lost to us because of
this obsession with individualism.
We mentioned and I've,
uh,
somewhat frame this conversation within
the idea that there is an imposition of
progressivism on,
uh,
but on former colonized nations by
former colonial nations,
enough,
uh,
competing at low,
less powerful,
but I think still interesting story is
the raw and,
and perhaps a component of Orient,
Orient Elysium is the romanticization
that also comes from sort of I suppose.
So they like,
cause for me,
meeting you as an Indian man that grew
up in a small town and me as a person
who's a,
and my body is smothered in tattoos from
your great scriptures of figures and
icons and gods from your scriptures.
And cause I write literal text.
Yeah,
yeah.
Love smothered in Bloody Sanskrit,
Krishna's here connect.
She's here,
the Shakras are there.
Oh,
I was smothered in all this stuff.
So there's this sort of like this sort
of,
the other component of orientalism is a
software Western fetishization of a and
possibly a reductively of,
uh,
of Hindu ideology or vedic knowledge.
And so no,
but do you think that there is a genuine
value that can be useful in a sort of
postmodern?
Far Too much easy mockery and criticism
of people who look to all the cultures
or,
or ancient philosophies,
whether in Asia or elsewhere in Africa
or,
or Latin America or the Americas.
Because what they are looking for is an
alternative to a way of being,
to a civilization that feels too much
like a trap to them.
And I think,
you know,
people in the 60s or went out to places
like India and joined various
countercultural moments,
most famously the Beatles.
And I know there was so many,
they were literally hundreds of
thousands of people who went out there
looking for an alternative to this.
So less mechanical society that they
were living in,
which was at that time in the 1960s
engaged in a catastrophic violent war in
Vietnam and indies elsewhere.
So there was a lot of disillusionment
back then,
which made people look for some kind of
a spiritual and moral possibility
elsewhere.
And I think that impulse is important,
that impulse,
which can mislead.
And he did mislead a lot of people,
uh,
into joining all kinds of crazy sex,
um,
being cornered by various gurus who were
just waiting for these gullible people
to show up.
But I think it's really important to
understand why these people went out
there and that it's also important to
understand that there is a lot of value.
There is,
there are many things of value in these
traditions.
These are these,
this is,
this is how human beings lived for
centuries and centuries.
We would be foolish to discard the
wisdom contained in those traditions and
philosophies.
How do we utilize it,
do you imagine?
Because,
uh,
of course this is wisdom premised on a
very different time on different
conditions,
but I sense that morally and spiritually
there's a value in it.
Can it like in defiance of the essence
of secularism,
do these spiritual models have
information that ought be utilized in
the establishment of new social systems?
In your opinion?
You know,
someone like the Dalai Lama,
who,
who I rate very highly,
who is a Buddhist,
but when he goes around the world,
he insists that he's not really talking
about Buddhism.
He's talking about compassion,
the importance of compassion.
So He's coming from an ancient religious
tradition.
He's completely immersed in it.
He's using that language,
but he's not saying that you have to
become a Buddhist.
You have to convert to my way of life.
He's saying these are some of the
principles outlined,
embraced by human beings a long time ago
and since then followed by hundreds of
millions of people and they have been
hugely,
hugely important and making possible
contented lives.
So you have to think about this as an
alternative to these stress stouts,
intolerable lives that you're leading
out there,
which is causing all kinds of
psychological disorders.
So I think you know,
when you start thinking about it in
these pragmatic ways,
when you shed this baggage of religious
tradition or spiritual tradition,
when again,
you think about the basic building
blocks of human society,
compassion and solidarity,
those resources you can find in many
different religious traditions including
those in the west.
I think it's really important too to
realize it.
Western Europe,
the United States,
is it cell full of those vital
traditions.
When you talk about the basic building
blocks of human society or so of course
talking about the basic building blocks
of a human being and a the,
if these energies,
these Schumer's these components of a
human being include compassion,
kindness,
community,
togetherness,
Union Union and yearning,
at least for the,
for the last few things I mentioned,
then these are,
uh,
perhaps I favorable resource to under
route raw underwrite our social systems
compared to these sort of individualism
that has become rampant and is leading
into deterioration is something I've
brought up several times in this
podcast.
I'd like to know what you think about it
in the moment prior to Indian
independence from Britain,
Gandy said that there's no point in us
replacing the British merely to emulate
them and to maintain their systems.
I'm sure you're aware.
And as it was,
he said he spoke sort of that 60 70
years ago whenever it was said like
that,
you know that this is a country of
70,000
villages.
All of them should be the PA perhaps
into dependent but autonomous and free
and,
and he set that sort of like that,
you know,
so it was talked in a way about sort of
a decentralized social system.
And he also talks about,
and I've not mentioned this is march
something,
but he said people will have to to some
degree let go of their need for
commodification.
There need to consume.
And it seems sort of again,
sort of a as ear really perspicacious to
hear someone talk about,
you can't be obsessed with your iphone
for half a century prior to that,
that kind of technology being available.
But it seemed to me very pertinent.
But there is that we have to let go.
This a narrative of progressivism that
keeps coming up is aligned to the
liberal idea of individual freedom,
which is aligned to consuming to make
yourself happy and at some point where
the rubber meets the road,
individual human beings like me.
And you said earlier,
we are sort of prisoners of comfort,
addicted to the privileges that the last
2030 years is afforded us.
At some point does it,
it boils down to us saying we've got
just have less stuff and we've got to
let go of it.
It's not working for us.
And that might be a component of
building different kinds of societies.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
socialism for a long time carried many
of the impulses leftover from faded
Christianity feeling of compassion,
uh,
charity justice.
Okay.
When social socialism ones realized in
certain countries,
again,
because socialism became all about
material growth,
material progress,
these values were systematically
disregarded.
But I think it's really important to
marry socialist ideas,
primarily those of compassion,
equality,
justice to this regard for the
environment.
Nature recognition of kind.
Gandhi had very early on in the 1920s
and thirties.
I mean,
he was early figure of the green
movement that the earth does not have
enough resources to fulfill all the
greedy desires we have for,
uh,
gadgets failed or amenities for life
that we have to learn and practice.
The virtue of renunciation is that that
is a very,
very important,
uh,
value for the society we live in.
And again,
this is not someone talking in a vacuum.
This is someone,
and this is an aspect of him that's
elected.
This is the one who has lived in three
continents before the first world war.
He's lived in Africa,
he's lived in India,
he's lived in Europe.
This is the man with a wide experience
of world that has been globalized during
his time.
Yes.
He,
he understands that this model,
it's essentially it's premised on
violence.
Yes.
He can see that because he's living
under imperialism.
He sees the,
okay,
violence is at the core of this whole
process.
And that is why India cannot afford to
follow this path.
And,
and you know,
he,
he did say that we don't want to
essentially,
uh,
replace rule by rule of the Englishman
by English Raj.
Yeah.
So we need to think again about what
kind of society we want for ourselves
because following this model of and
growth consumption oriented growth is
going to lead us into an impasse.
This concealed violence,
uh,
the,
this,
uh,
the,
the necessity of this model to conceal
it's means and its motives is something
addressed by Marxist theory.
And it's,
I suppose predicate it simply on the
idea that you can't have limitless
growth if you've got limited resources
in the end,
this will not even in the end sit
clinically.
This will lead to crisis.
So capitalism at its heart needs to
conceal both its means and its motives.
Um,
that at its core there is a kind of
nihilism and like,
well,
we don't care which is going to carry on
doing.
It doesn't matter.
I don't think about it.
Sort of a sort of a weird psychopathic
modus operandi.
Um,
it's interesting to me that you sort of
spoke of a kind of an emergent sense of
nihilism.
And the despair that we experienced as a
result of this nihilism because
precisely because we are beginning to
experience while continue while we're
continue,
while the lie is sort of still sort of
propped up with a by quantitative easing
or are compliant media new iphone
upgrade.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean I take them whenever they're
offered.
No,
I'm not the one I found 10 now.
Yeah.
The,
these continues to be concealed.
So,
uh,
well what I'm asking I suppose
is La,
where will,
where do you,
like you,
you,
you saying that it will lead to impasse,
but it's perhaps likely that this rage
will lead somewhere
darker.
Do you,
where do you envisage it?
Well,
you know,
in many ways the solutions to many of
the problems that exist today,
political problems,
economic problems,
inequality,
dysfunction,
that pretty obvious if you're diagnosed
the problem correctly,
the problems,
the,
the prescriptions of the solutions
would,
would emerge naturally from that.
The problem really is the,
whether anyone or any party,
any movement has the political will to
do it.
The establishment at present,
whether in,
in,
in Europe or in America.
I do not think it's capable of charting
a new path of leading us out of this
impasse.
Marsha depends on social movements,
on political movements,
on the energy,
intellectual dynamism,
dynamism of young people who are
entering public life for the first time
with new ideas,
with no prejudices,
no fantasies about themselves,
about their imperialist past and,
and,
and what their ancestors achieved in the
second world war and so on.
And these are people that we should look
to us.
I mean,
I feel like my generation was a,
was a failure.
Um,
I'm in,
I'm in now,
um,
uh,
approaching my,
my,
uh,
um,
late forties,
and I feel that my generation was too
much in thrall to these notions of
universal progress and growth that
started to be globalized back off back
in the late eighties,
early nineties.
And it's a generation that has not been
intoxicated by this kind of thinking.
Yes,
that's very experienced,
is different,
is very,
is very distinctly,
is one,
should never underestimate the power of
a generation remake or young generation
to remake the world.
Okay.
Curious the identity and fluidity,
a PA to be sort of a determining
component of the younger generation
where they don't want to be labeled.
They either around sexuality and
identity.
There is a sort of,
there is a sort of a new fluidity that
bodes well for transitioning and change
on a social and political.
I think it's fantastic.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
all our rigid categories,
um,
masculine,
feminine for instance.
I mean we've been,
we've been experiencing now for the last
few months,
this sort of explosion of,
um,
stories about this whole culture of
oppression that has existed in the heart
of the modern world.
Again,
something that used to be blamed
exclusively on Islam or religion,
the oppression of women,
the exploitation of women.
And now we see a,
it,
there's pathology existing in the
citadel.
Absolutely.
Uh,
within corporate cultures.
You know,
and I think what it is telling us that,
uh,
lot of this oppression is systemic.
Yeah.
These,
it's premised on these rigid separations
of,
of you know,
mescaline roles,
feminine rules and this identity
blurring and fluidity that we sue today
is an attempt,
whether it's deliberate or not,
it's certainly a very admirable,
is trying to transcend these categories
that actually create oppressive
conditions for,
for many,
many people.
That's brilliant insight.
Thank you very much.
That means to ask you a few more sort
of,
uh,
questions that relate to your work and
sort of bring us to this pretty salient.
The,
we touched on the recent recent amount.
Am I saying it correct?
I really liked that.
Um,
what's,
uh,
like can you unpack the kick card aspect
of that day to turn the kicker God used
and how it relates to terrorism?
I think,
you know,
um,
for Kierkegaard [inaudible] was
something that emerges when individuals
are made to think that they are equal.
Okay.
Why did the same time they confront the
fact the brute fact structural
inequality.
So it's this collision between the
feeling that you're equal,
that you all have the same opportunities
that you are in the same social level,
and then you encounter the fact that
some people are much better off,
that there are structural injustices at
work,
historical injustices at work that make
some people more privileged than others.
He diagnosed this as a problem peculiar
to modern society because societies in
the past did not uphold the quality as
an ideal or as a value.
These are hierarchical societies.
Okay.
[inaudible] know they did not think
about instituting equality as an idea.
It's more than society that thinks of
equality as a central idea,
but at the same time,
because of the process of
industrialization,
because of all these other things that
start to happen in the 19th century and
kick your God is writing in the 19th
century,
in the mid 19th century,
he can see that there's a contradiction
opening up between the promise of
equality between the promise of freedom
and the growth of institutions that deny
people equality and freedom.
And it's sin.
That denial that the feeling of the
[inaudible] germinates Oh,
brilliant.
So he identified a fundamental
contradiction.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
Sorry drew.
So although he did not use the word
resulting more,
um,
but he,
he,
he did point to some central
contradictions in the modern project
that what we are trying to achieve will
not be achieved because there are some,
there is something just intrinsically
contradictory about pursuing equality in
a society where competition,
vanity,
imitation,
our values and ideas,
these values I find personally very
punishing and I experienced all of them
quite deeply.
Vanity plays a big role in my life and
has done and it's something I'm very
aware of and I'm trying to diminish his
role.
Competition is a not good feeling to
feel I'm not good enough.
I have to be better than these people,
these,
these models.
I expect that when I like,
cause one of the reason I started doing
this a podcast is because I go to the,
so as university in London doing a
degree in religion in global politics.
Really?
Yeah.
And at the moment I'm doing a module of
a sort of the,
the roots of the traditions of yoga.
So it's looking at a lot of vedic texts,
your pan,
upanishads,
et cetera.
And whenever I'm listening to the
lectures or reason about it and I sort
of have been doing this generally across
the course,
I feel like what does this matter to
mean now?
What do these values mean to me right
now in this room,
in this world,
on this planet,
in these systems right now.
And get it.
Cause I can see the impact of vanity.
I can see the failure of narcissism,
I'm experiencing it.
I'm experiencing the failure of
consumerism.
I'm seeing the way that I'm inhibited
and limited by these ideas.
A moment ago you said like if you
correctly diagnose the problem,
then the prescription becomes obvious,
which is a pretty cool catch me
actually.
I reckon you should start pushing that.
Uh,
so,
um,
what,
what do you diagnose as the problem and
is it like with all of these
complexities and on the scale that we
now live with,
which is,
you know,
glide,
but globalization,
whether you regard it as pejorative as
it now generally is,
or positives,
it was just a 10,
15 years ago.
How do,
how does one come up with a central
universal solutions too?
Well,
the probably isn't a central university
tuition.
I mean I think uh,
it's probably a mistake to look for
central university,
the solution right now because the
problem you could say was in thinking
that there is a universal model of
progress.
The fact that all of us wherever we are
have to device ideas,
solutions for our societies,
the nectar too.
Okay.
Real experience of her circumstances off
the actual physical,
geographical,
political,
historical conditions that'd be inherit
this can only mean forms of devolution.
Decentralization.
Yes.
You know,
it,
it the,
the implications of this diagnosis in,
in,
in many different realms.
Um,
so you know,
politically we have to think more about
decentralization.
We have to think about people being
empowered,
people feeling that they are in control
of their lives.
So what do you make of people like on
the left that say that without some form
of dominant state power there will the,
the,
the idea of anarchy is a pejorative or
negative state emerges like that,
you know,
when I sort of say look cause for a
while and some of these conversations
I've got,
it seems like the like are our
requirements and our needs are so
diverse.
We need the power to be as close as
possible to the people that are affected
by that power.
People should run their own workplaces,
their own hospitals,
their own schools,
their own communities and power.
She'll be devolved,
decentralized wherever possible.
And what the feedback I've had from sofa
as suppose in know traditional leftist
thinkers and some people that are very
much respect and admire is that without
some authority,
some sort of state or far even without
some kind of central power,
these projects we'll foul.
Can you send it?
I can understand that concern because
you know,
um,
something that has been said over and
over again in the last 20,
30 years of new liberalism is that the
state needs to step back and let's
essentially society be governed
according to market principles.
Yes.
So there is very good reason to be
suspicious of that argument which wants
to roll back the role of government in
protecting the weak and the vulnerable.
Yes,
yes.
And giving ceding power to market forces
and we know who benefits from,
from uh,
the free play of market forces.
At the same time,
I think a history has shown repeatedly
that states when invested with too much
power,
toning into oppressive,
impersonal bureaucracies,
that is the experience of many
communists states,
eastern European states.
And so we have to be careful.
We have to strike a balance between a
state that is responsive to it's
citizens that doesn't a choir and a not
Thomas' life that doesn't stop living
for itself.
So we have to,
there has to be a role for the state.
At the same time,
citizens have to feel that the decisions
they are taking,
the people they are choosing as their
representatives are responsive to them.
Okay.
That they are in a politically
functional society.
I think what we have today is a deeply
dysfunctional political society.
Okay.
Yes.
Evidently.
What do you think of like a new heroes
of the left's,
uh,
Jeremy Corbyn,
this country,
Bernie Sanders that know if that's
relevant anymore in America or would be
in the next election cycle if that's
already something that's over and done
with,
Eh,
do you think that within the conditions,
the democratic conditions as we
currently find them,
that they would be able to represent
people's interest?
This is recent.
Like Jeremy Corbyn,
Sam Morgan Stanley should be afraid,
you know,
like,
do you,
do you think that there is,
to coin the author,
use the name of the movement,
the backs,
Corbyn genuine momentum in that
direction?
Do you think that with within democracy
as we have it in this country,
the,
that he would be empowered to take
action in that direction?
You know,
I think I'm more interested in,
in the movements then.
Then in actual personalities.
I think it's remarkable that within a
few months,
eh,
massive movements consisting largely of
very young people politicize young
people came together and became a huge
presence in British politics.
That to me is more important than you
know,
the,
the play of individuals.
I mean,
you know,
Jeremy Corban is a,
is an important figure in that he was
the one who crystallize a popular
feeling,
a feeling that was not being articulated
by certainly not the press,
not by a commentators.
He managed to recognize that a lot of
people in this country for ready for
change,
for new ways of thinking.
Now whether he is politically successful
or not,
the important thing is that he's already
created a movement is already affected.
It dramatic shifts in how people think
about
what should be done here.
Yes.
But part of my question,
pancake is what within democracy,
as we currently experience it as it
exists now,
would a political party led by Corbyn or
someone of a similar sensibility be able
to enact the will of the people?
Or would there be too much bureaucratic
and systemic resistance and eh,
and it does the state with the have
sufficient power to confront eg
transnational corporations.
You know,
the odds are stacked against 'em anyone
trying to affect any movement,
any individual trying to affect radical
change in this society especially,
which is a very conservative society,
uh,
where all kinds of ancient powers are
entrenched.
Okay.
Unlike most societies in Europe,
which experience revolution experienced,
um,
some kind of national upheaval that's
overturn the old order,
introduce new elements,
we have to recognize that Britain never
really had a revolution.
So Brandon,
pretty unique.
Think that's extremely,
I mean,
it's,
it's singular.
Russia had one,
France has a American side one.
What did you watch Germany's then the
failure of the Second World War?
Well,
Joe Jones went through all kinds of
traumas.
You know,
even even before the Second World War.
So first one went very good.
I mean they,
they,
they had to unify.
They had to sort of create a nation
state in the first place in,
in the,
in the 19th century.
Britain is really unique and one reason
British politics has been so different
from everywhere else.
What has remained conservative for such
a long time and why,
you know,
a certain kind of English,
upper class landowning aristocracy still
exercises enormous influence here.
This is unprecedented,
really unprecedented.
And in the entire world you can't think
of any other country with that kind of
institutional power invested in
traditional elites.
How fascinating.
So I say we're in a unique society.
This is why someone,
you know,
uh,
venturing on a radical project of
political economic transformation is up
against it.
I mean,
there's no point in,
in,
you know,
uh,
being overly optimistic by the one has
to recognize that there are formidable
challenges.
Head.
Do you think that the role of religion
may be as if not more important as
politics as we understand it in any
significant social change?
Well,
if you're talking about Britain,
you know,
the role of religion has been declining
so dramatically,
so rapidly that one can't really think
of it as a,
as a sort of political factor really
anymore.
Religion remains a alive in other
societies,
but unfortunately once religion is
mobilized as a political force,
beny turns into ideology,
then it moves away from what people are
talking about earlier.
This belief in a transcendental
authority,
which in many ways is a source of
constellation,
a source of peace.
Uh,
it,
it pacifies many people,
it makes them more kind and
compassionate.
But when religion is used as an
ideology,
as a way of mobilizing people,
it is inevitably a recipe for conflict.
Because then what people want to do is
to say,
well,
this community or this particular group
does not belong.
Yes,
that is isn't conflict and violence
isn't conflict.
Certainly in violence regrettably and
necessary component in radical change,
probably not violence.
You know,
there are,
there are instances of societies which
have recovered from great violence and
rebuild themselves through largely
nonviolent means.
There has been conflict.
Inevitably there'll be conflict because
the old guard is,
is,
is not going to let go of it's Baba.
I mean,
you know,
power never really concedes anything
unless you make stern demands on it.
So there is inevitably going to be
conflict.
But violence,
um,
I think violence can unleash a cycle
where we will,
you know,
continue to employ violent means to
pursue your ends and inflict more on
more damage on the social fabric of
society.
I mean,
this is,
you know,
this has been the experience of many
societies.
Bishop hired violent revolutions and
undermine themselves and took a long
time for them to recover from that kind
of prime of violence.
Yeah.
Nonviolence as a method for protest for
like,
you know,
when you're talking about sort of the
old guard and the resistance of the old
guard,
you can see that there's these
entrenched,
and you said ancient powers in this
country you referring to,
but you know,
can see sort of even modern or authority
that refuses to yield.
Uh,
like that.
One of the,
you said like the last time there was a
huge civil unrest or like are around
identity politics around sort of an
empowerment of you for at the Marne for
change different ideas was the 60s and
we saw by the nonviolence huge component
of that I suppose between in a way,
because it would probably because of the
infusion of sort of different ae,
eastern mystic or to Luther King and the
influence on Martin Luther King of
Gandy.
Very direct and explicit and expressed.
And uh,
I know,
and I suppose because it was being
counter post with such obvious domestic
violence in the United States against
the African American population in
violence on the young men and women that
have incentive Vietnam to fight.
So I suppose it seemed like an eh,
evident and obvious.
And it though,
I wonder if,
uh,
I wonder if you can envisage mass
movements towards decentralization.
There's something sort of contradictory
about it,
but that people coming together
achieving solidarity to demand the right
to be autonomous,
to demand the dismantling of centralized
interest institutions that prevent
people having real purchase,
real power,
real purpose.
You know,
there are instances of,
um,
movements for decentralization,
which turned into secessionist
movements,
sometimes inevitably such as,
um,
cartoon.
Yeah.
Um,
people,
a lot of people in Hong Kong for
instance,
they want the freedom to run their own
affairs.
Um,
you will,
you could argue that large numbers of
people in Scotland want to be free of a
country that is hurtling a disaster,
but a disaster spot too.
It's brexit.
So right now we see more cessationists
tendencies,
you know,
which are a kind of replacement for a
movement.
That means what,
just sort of breaking away from existing
nation state
structures and forming an independent
sovereign nation state.
Why it doesn't,
it doesn't solve the problem of
centralization
there.
And why,
like under those terms,
couldn't brexit be regarded as quite a
positive thing if we're talking about
decentralization or do you see the
European Union is largely benevolent in
confront,
in economics to be made from the left
for Brexit?
Yes.
I've always believed that,
um,
it was never made,
nobody bothered to make it.
Um,
the fact that,
um,
Britain should exercise greater
sovereignty and should not have
decisions made by mobile global capital.
You know,
I think we have to understand the
impulse behind these apparently
kilometers phenomenal like brexit or
trump,
which is essentially people really do
want to take back control.
Yes.
The people promising control to them
happened to be at this point,
demagogues core interested in expanding
their own power and those of their
cronies.
Okay.
This does not mean that the platform,
that's the four tone,
which was the idea of taking back
control is not hugely attractive numbers
of people who really do genuinely want
to take back into who do want to be
empowered,
who do not want their lives to be
determined by the impersonal,
abstract forces of,
of capital.
They do want to be repulsed,
decide their societies to be repleted
decides that,
uh,
and,
and wants economic imperatives or indeed
the imperatives of profit,
corporate profits to override human
values,
human considerations.
But if it's,
if,
if the far right or the devil Gawks,
if they are the only ones channeling
this energy.
Okay.
Two was their own ends.
Then we end up with these in these
situations that we are in right now.
I really,
I think that's a very optimistic
analysis.
By don't mean a romantic analysis,
I think it's quite pragmatic and quite
powerful.
Uh,
thank you.
I appreciate that.
But when you were saying that if you
diagnosed the problem correctly,
then the prescription becomes obvious
and if indeed we are living in,
let me quote you at the title,
your book,
age of anger,
then compassion is necessarily the
prescription compassion for one another.
So I think that,
you know,
both for honest,
from a spiritual perspective and from a
practical political perspective,
I think I've learned a great deal from
this conversation and I can envisage,
I really understood the story,
their philosophical story or historical
narrative in ways that I haven't before
and it gave me cause for optimism and
that,
you know,
I've never been a person that saw brexit
is a wholly oh negative thing.
I,
because of the background I come from,
I have a different attitude towards
that.
Sort of the idea of what brexit might
mean and what people might have meant
when they said it.
And that take back power,
take back control as an impulse needn't
necessarily be,
uh,
aimed at like,
because we hate these group of people
because we hate that group of people.
Uh,
thank you very much for explaining that
to me.
Thank you.
It's been a wonderful conversation.
I really enjoyed it.
Yeah,
me too man.
Thanks Pankaj Mishra.
Thank you very much for coming here.
Thanks for participating in the skin.
It really enjoyed that.
Likewise.
Good when it know I very much enjoyed
that.
There we go.
That show was sponsored by my book
recovery,
which is available now.
You can order it on Amazon.
Also get the audiobook of Audubon.
It was pretty good.
And also come and see me on the rebirth
tour.
A lot of these ideas are presented in
succinct,
amusing,
sometimes disgusting ways.
Leicester,
December the sixth,
Newcastle,
14th of December,
Brixton,
December the 19th.
And that's it.
And that'll be it for the year.
So a go russell,
brand.com
if you want tickets for that.
And finally,
just to trouble you a little bit more,
ring a bit more of your life.
If you like this show,
please subscribe and review it on Itunes
or wherever you get it,
and give it five stars because it helps
us to get better advertising and stuff
like that.
All right.
Thanks for listening.
Bye.